This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Memphis, Tennessee is home to many historic landmarks like Graceland and Beale Street, but one of their biggest tourist magnets is a Bass Pro Shop. Usually, Bass Pro is the place to buy hunting and fishing gear. Bass producer Chris Berube. But the one in Memphis, it's less of a store and more of a camo-colored amusement park. On the main floor, there are fiberglass cypress trees
这里是《99% Invisible》，我是罗曼·马尔斯。田纳西州的孟菲斯市拥有许多历史地标，比如雅园和比尔街，但他们最大的旅游磁石之一却是Bass Pro Shop（户外用品店）。通常，Bass Pro是购买狩猎和钓鱼装备的地方。Bass制作人克里斯·贝鲁比。但孟菲斯的那家店，与其说是一家商店，不如说是一个迷彩色的游乐园。在一楼，有玻璃纤维制的柏树，
that are about 100 feet tall, and there's an enclosure with baby alligators. They have a fake swamp that is filled with real fish and a crossbow range and an arcade where kids can take target practice with plastic guns, which gave this Passifist Canadian a few moments of pause. Across the way I see a man showing his infant child how to load a gun. It's a little unnerving.
大约有100英尺高，还有一个养着小短吻鳄的围栏。他们有一个装满真鱼的假沼泽，一个弩箭靶场，还有一个游乐厅，孩子们可以在那里用塑料枪进行打靶练习，这让这位和平主义的加拿大人感到了一阵迟疑。在对面，我看到一个男人正在教他年幼的孩子如何装弹。这让人有点不安。
It can feel completely surreal to be inside the Memphis Bass Pro, and making it double strange is the fact that the store itself is a 32-story stainless steel pyramid. The giant pyramid is hard to miss. The building itself is about two-thirds the height of the Pyramids of Giza, and the base is about the size of three Walmarts. It is the first thing you see driving into Memphis on Interstate 40. On one side you have, you know, glass office towers, typical downtown stuff, and then the other side, WAM, giant pyramid, covered in reflective stainless steel panels and a Bass
身处孟菲斯Bass Pro内部会让人感到极其超现实，而让它加倍奇怪的是，这家店本身就是一座32层高的不锈钢金字塔。这座巨大的金字塔很难被忽视。建筑本身的高度大约是吉萨金字塔的三分之二，底座大约有三个沃尔玛那么大。它是你开车沿40号州际公路进入孟菲斯时看到的第一样东西。一边是玻璃办公大楼，典型的市中心建筑，而另一边，砰，巨大的金字塔，覆盖着反光不锈钢板，还有一个Bass
Pro logo that's over 75 feet tall. I went to check out the pyramid earlier this year, and for journalism purposes, I actually stayed inside a hotel connected to the pyramid. It's rustically called the Big Cypress Lodge. My room had three pieces of taxidermy and no windows, unless you count this little deck area that overlooks the sales floor. It's got two chairs, two rocking chairs, mosquito netting, in case mosquitoes come in from the Bass Pro Shop, I guess. I would look out onto the bustling store and then stare in awe at the spire of this giant pyramid, hundreds of feet up.
Pro标志，高度超过75英尺。今年早些时候，我去参观了这座金字塔，为了新闻报道，我实际上住进了与金字塔相连的一家酒店。它被质朴地称为大柏树旅馆（Big Cypress Lodge）。我的房间里有三件动物标本，没有窗户，除非你算上那个可以俯瞰卖场的小露台区域。那里有两把椅子，两把摇椅，还有蚊帐，我想是以防蚊子从Bass Pro Shop里飞进来。我会望向熙熙攘攘的商店，然后敬畏地凝视着这座巨大金字塔的尖顶，那可是几百英尺高。
The Memphis pyramid hasn't always been a Bass Pro. 35 years ago, civic leaders in Memphis had a totally different plan for it, and it's had a few tenants over the years before becoming a woodsy mall. The story of the Great American Pyramid is long and completely bizarre, and its trajectory shows how, in architecture and urban planning, the life of a building
孟菲斯的金字塔并不总是Bass Pro。35年前，孟菲斯的市政领导人对它有着完全不同的计划，在成为木质风格的购物中心之前，它多年来换过几任租户。关于这座“伟大的美国金字塔”的故事既漫长又完全离奇，它的轨迹展示了在建筑和城市规划中，一栋建筑的生命
can be impossible to predict. It might sound ridiculous to build a pyramid in modern times, let alone building one in a major American city. But for the past 200 years, every Western power has borrowed design ideas from ancient Egypt. After the French invasion of Egypt in 1798, where you can see a lot of influence in architecture, art, furnishings and so forth. Dr. Chris Elliott is an Egyptologist who is currently a visiting fellow at the University of Southampton. He says you could see Egyptian designs everywhere in the architecture and the monuments of Western
是多么难以预测。在现代建造一座金字塔听起来可能很荒谬，更不用说在美国的一个大城市里建造它了。但在过去的200年里，每一个西方大国都从古埃及借用了设计理念。在1798年法国入侵埃及之后，你在建筑、艺术、家具等方面可以看到很多影响。克里斯·埃利奥特博士是一位埃及古物学家，目前是南安普顿大学的访问学者。他说，你可以在西方建筑和纪念碑中随处看到埃及设计，
Europe in the 18th and 19th centuries. I mean I'm fond of paraphrasing the famous lines from Jane Austen's Pride and Prejudice. You know, it appears that any nation in possession of an empire must be in want of an obelisk. That trend was called Egyptomania, and it jumped over to America in the 19th century. Designers were putting sphinx heads on chairs and designing public buildings with faux Egyptian accents.
特别是在18和19世纪的欧洲。我的意思是，我喜欢改写简·奥斯汀《傲慢与偏见》中的名句。你知道，似乎任何拥有帝国的国家都必然需要一座方尖碑。这种趋势被称为“埃及热”，并在19世纪传到了美国。设计师们把狮身人面像的头放在椅子上，并用仿埃及风格装饰公共建筑。
I think part of this was showing that you weren't just Nouveau-Riche. You were traveled, you were educated, you had taste as well. You can also see Egyptomania in public buildings like courthouses and city halls that are made to look Egyptian. The Washington Monument,
我认为这部分是为了表明你不仅仅是“暴发户”。你游历广泛，受过教育，而且有品位。你也可以在法院和市政厅等公共建筑中看到埃及热，它们被设计成埃及风格。华盛顿纪念碑，
that's just one big old Egyptian obelisk. The city of Memphis, Tennessee is perhaps the peak of this trend. Memphis was named after the capital of ancient Egypt, and the city's founders picked the name because Memphis, Tennessee is nestled beside America's most powerful river, the Mississippi. There's this long-standing tradition of the Mississippi as the American Nile. Apart from anyone else, Abraham Lincoln actually used that metaphor. tradition of the Mississippi as the American Nile, apart from anyone else, Abraham Lincoln
那不过是一座巨大的古埃及方尖碑。田纳西州的孟菲斯市也许是这种趋势的巅峰。孟菲斯是以古埃及首都的名字命名的，城市创始人选择这个名字是因为孟菲斯坐落在美洲最强大的河流——密西西比河畔。密西西比河作为“美国尼罗河”有着悠久的传统。除了其他人之外，亚伯拉罕·林肯实际上也使用过这个隐喻。密西西比河作为“美国尼罗河”的传统，除了其他人之外，亚伯拉罕·林肯
actually used that metaphor. So naturally the city of Memphis needed its own big, ancient Egyptian attraction. Obelisk was kind of taken because, you know, the Washington Monument. So instead they went with a pyramid. A wooden pyramid was constructed in 1897 to represent the city at the Centennial Fair in Nashville.
实际上也使用过这个隐喻。所以自然地，孟菲斯市需要它自己宏伟的古埃及景点。方尖碑已经被占用了，因为，你知道，华盛顿纪念碑。所以他们选择了金字塔。1897年，一座木制金字塔被建造出来，以代表该市参加纳什维尔的百年博览会。
The wooden pyramid wasn't used for anything after the fair, so they tore it down. But a local artist revived the pyramid idea about a half a century later. In the 1950s, this artist named Mark Harts drew up a plan for three pyramids. This is Martha Park, a local author and illustrator who has written about the Memphis Pyramid. They would be bronze colored along the riverfront and they would be like two-thirds the size of the pyramids in Giza. The trio of bronze pyramids were never built, but over the years, the idea of a permanent gigantic pyramid
博览会结束后，这座木制金字塔就没再派上用场，于是他们把它拆了。但半个世纪后，一位当地艺术家复兴了金字塔的想法。20世纪50年代，这位名叫马克·哈茨的艺术家绘制了一份建造三座金字塔的计划。这是玛莎·帕克，一位写过关于孟菲斯金字塔的当地作家和插画家。它们将是青铜色的，位于河滨，大小约为吉萨金字塔的三分之二。这三座青铜金字塔从未建成，但多年来，为孟菲斯市中心建造一座永久性巨型金字塔的想法
for downtown Memphis stuck around, especially among civic leaders who wanted outsiders to think of Memphis for something other than Elvis and the blues. I think it's this kind of attempt to have this like monolithic representation of the city, like the bean in Chicago, the arch in St. Louis, it will just mean Memphis to other people's brains.
一直存在，特别是在那些希望外地人想到孟菲斯时不仅仅想到猫王和蓝调音乐的市政领导人中。我认为这是一种试图拥有这种像纪念碑一样的城市代表物的尝试，就像芝加哥的“豆子”、圣路易斯的拱门一样，它在别人的脑海中就代表了孟菲斯。
For years, the pyramid was just this quirky, unrealized civic project. But in the mid-80s, the planets finally lined up. The city needed a new downtown landmark. The college basketball team, the Memphis Tigers, were selling out all of their home games, and they needed a bigger arena. At the same time, it was the peak of postmodernism in American architecture. Cities all over the US were commissioning buildings that borrowed details from Greece, ancient Rome, and yes, ancient Egypt. So city and county officials formed a public building authority and announced they would spend $39 million on a brand new basketball arena in the shape of a giant pyramid. The Memphis Building Authority chose to construct the pyramid with stainless steel instead of
多年来，金字塔只是一个古怪的、未实现的市政项目。但在80年代中期，行星终于对齐了。该市需要一个新的市中心地标。大学篮球队“孟菲斯老虎队”的主场比赛场场爆满，他们需要一个更大的竞技场。与此同时，那是美国建筑界后现代主义的巅峰时期。美国各地的城市都在委托建造借用希腊、古罗马，当然还有古埃及细节的建筑。因此，市和县的官员成立了一个公共建筑管理局，并宣布他们将花费3900万美元建造一个巨大的金字塔形状的全新篮球场。孟菲斯建筑管理局选择用不锈钢而不是
bronze, and it picked a location in the city's historic Pinch District. Pinch was a name from the Irish settlers that came in from the Irish potato famine in the 1860s. The Pinch Gut District, because their stomachs had the pinched in look like a skinny man. That's Jimmy Ogle. He used to be the official historian for Shelby County, which includes Memphis. He says the Pinch District had gone through waves of immigration, before it was basically cut in half by a highway in the 1960s. It was after urban renewal, but all that was going on in the 60s with the urban renewal of all cities, and we called it urban removal in a lot of ways.
青铜来建造金字塔，并选择了该市历史悠久的“捏区”（Pinch District）作为地点。Pinch这个名字来自19世纪60年代爱尔兰马铃薯饥荒时期涌入的爱尔兰定居者。“捏胃区”（Pinch Gut District），因为他们的胃看起来像瘦子一样凹陷。那是吉米·奥格尔。他曾是谢尔比县（包括孟菲斯）的官方历史学家。他说，Pinch区经历了多波移民潮，在20世纪60年代被一条高速公路一分为二之前。那是在城市更新之后，但60年代所有城市都在进行城市更新，我们在很多方面称之为“城市移除”。
City leaders felt the pyramid could help rejuvenate the economy and bring more people into downtown Memphis. Plus, there was this big tract of land in the Pinch right alongside the Mississippi River, the fabled Nile of America. In 1988, the city and county voted to build the pyramid in the Pinch District with public money. The arena would give the neighborhood a shot in the arm. It would give the Tigers another 10,000 seats,
城市领导人认为金字塔可以帮助振兴经济，并将更多人带到孟菲斯市中心。此外，在密西西比河畔的Pinch区有一大片土地，也就是传说中的“美国尼罗河”。1988年，市和县投票决定用公共资金在Pinch区建造金字塔。这个竞技场将为该社区注入活力。它将为老虎队提供另外10,000个座位，
and it would give the city the pyramid-shaped monolith it had always dreamed of. A unique aspect of the pyramid shape is that it would have a lot of unused space around the arena, and all this space attracted a couple of enterprising businessmen. A local entrepreneur named John Tigrett helped convince the city to build the pyramid, partly because he wanted to help run it. Tigrett was famous for owning the patent on the drinky duck toy that bobs up and down
并将为这座城市提供它一直梦想的金字塔形巨石。金字塔形状的一个独特之处在于，竞技场周围会有很多未使用的空间，而所有这些空间吸引了一些有进取心的商人。一位名叫约翰·蒂格雷特的当地企业家帮助说服了该市建造金字塔，部分原因是他想帮助经营它。蒂格雷特因拥有在水中上下浮动的“饮水鸟”玩具的专利而闻名，
in a glass of water, among other more serious business ventures. But in the 1980s, he saw the pyramid as a great opportunity. Tigrit was interested in building some attractions inside the building. To help with this, Tigrit recruited another businessman named Sidney Schlanker. Schlanker had helped open the Astrodome in Houston, and he was the owner of the Denver Nuggets basketball team. He was a crazy bastard. He couldn't finish his first idea before starting the second. Russ Simons was the general manager of the Memphis Pyramid in the early 90s, and he says Sidney Schlanker was a very enthusiastic salesman.
此外还有其他更严肃的商业投资。但在20世纪80年代，他将金字塔视为一个巨大的机会。蒂格雷特有兴趣在建筑内建造一些景点。为了实现这一目标，蒂格雷特招募了另一位名叫西德尼·施兰克的商人。施兰克曾帮助开设了休斯顿的太空穹顶体育馆，并且是丹佛掘金篮球队的老板。他是个疯子。他还没完成第一个想法就开始了第二个。拉斯·西蒙斯是90年代初孟菲斯金字塔的总经理，他说西德尼·施兰克是一个非常热情的推销员。
He was a genius. He had to be, you know, probably just below Barnum in terms of his ability to sell. I'd put him a half step below P.T. Barnum. Yeah. Tigran and Schlinker struck a deal with the city. Basically, the city and county would construct the pyramid with public funds, and the businessmen would install $20 million worth of attractions throughout the building. Schlanker had a ton of ideas for the pyramid, many of which are summed up in this handy promotional video. A new pyramid is being built, not to glorify death, but as a monument that will celebrate life and man's indomitable spirit to create, to achieve a greatness that will reach to the stars
他是个天才。他必须是，你知道，在推销能力方面可能仅次于巴纳姆。我会把他排在P.T.巴纳姆之后半个身位。是的。蒂格雷特和施兰克与该市达成了一项协议。基本上，市和县将用公共资金建造金字塔，而商人们将在整栋建筑中安装价值2000万美元的景点。施兰克对金字塔有很多想法，其中许多都在这段方便的宣传视频中进行了总结。“一座新的金字塔正在建造中，不是为了美化死亡，而是作为一座纪念碑，将歌颂生命和人类创造的不屈精神，去实现一种能够触及星辰
and span centuries. A greatness that will save. Feel the power of the great American pyramid." I can't play this whole video because it's like 14 minutes long, but here's a quick summary. A narrator claims the pyramid would include attractions for the whole family, like a music hall of fame, a hard rock cafe, the world's largest transistor radio, and, sure, why not, a laser show. And just as the pyramids of old pull our thoughts to Egyptian culture, so too will this new pyramid be a calling card for the best of American civilization.
并跨越世纪的伟大。一种能够拯救的伟大。感受伟大的美国金字塔的力量。”我不能播放整个视频，因为它有14分钟长，但这里有一个简短的总结。旁白声称金字塔将包括适合全家人的景点，如音乐名人堂、硬石餐厅、世界上最大的晶体管收音机，当然，为什么不呢，还有激光表演。正如古老的金字塔吸引我们对埃及文化的思考一样，这座新的金字塔也将成为美国文明精华的名片。
The pyramid would also feature a state-of-the-art funicular called the inclinator. The inclinator was supposed to be an elevator running on a 45 degree incline along the inside of the building. With the inclinator, tourists could travel to an observation deck and marvel at the Mississippi River below. The hype was very strong. The video even compared the pyramid to some of the greatest wonders of the world, like the Sydney Opera House and the Arc de Triomphe, and even the
金字塔还将设有一个最先进的缆车，称为“倾斜升降机”（Inclinator）。倾斜升降机本应是一部沿着建筑内部45度斜坡运行的电梯。有了它，游客可以前往观景台，惊叹于下方的密西西比河。炒作非常强烈。视频甚至将金字塔与世界上一些最伟大的奇迹进行了比较，如悉尼歌剧院和凯旋门，甚至
Pyramids of Giza. Then it suggests the pyramid will probably be better than all of those other things. The way that they have it come up from the bottom of the screen and then overtake the picture of the Pyramids of Giza from behind it is like, forget all you know about pyramids, baby. I cannot overstate how much stuff was being promised here. The Memphis pyramid would be a totally unique building, an arena, and a museum, and a theme park, and a big elevator, and like a dozen other things.
吉萨金字塔。然后它暗示金字塔可能比所有其他东西都要好。他们让它从屏幕底部升起，然后从后面超越吉萨金字塔画面的方式就像是，忘掉你所知道的关于金字塔的一切吧，宝贝。我无法夸大这里承诺了多少东西。孟菲斯金字塔将是一座完全独特的建筑，一个竞技场，一个博物馆，一个主题公园，一部大电梯，以及其他十几种东西。
The vision for the pyramid, I'll just say was extraordinary. If that vision had been able to be brought to life, it would have been unlike anything else in the world. The city began construction on the pyramid in 1989. Well, the two businessmen drew up plans for what to put inside. Tigrit and Schlanker told the public they were going to spend millions of dollars on the pyramid and the surrounding neighborhood. But it slowly became clear that their plans weren't the most realistic, at least not at the scale they had promised. Schlinker commissioned the inclinator, but he didn't have enough money to mount it
我对金字塔的愿景，我只能说是非凡的。如果那个愿景能够实现，它将是世界上独一无二的。该市于1989年开始建造金字塔。好吧，两位商人制定了内部放置什么的计划。蒂格雷特和施兰克告诉公众，他们将在金字塔和周边社区花费数百万美元。但慢慢地，很明显他们的计划并不是最现实的，至少在他们承诺的规模上不是。施兰克委托建造了倾斜升降机，但他没有足够的钱把它安装
on the side of the building, and it was abandoned. Pretty soon, their struggles became obvious to the people of Memphis. If you talk to people in Memphis about Sidney Schlinker, it's very like, Schlinker. You know, it's like this kind of Newman kind of pronunciation. In the end, Schlinker and Tigrit had a public falling out. Their pyramid company filed for bankruptcy, and the city took them off the project altogether. The pyramid's construction was finished in 1991. The actual building was completed without Tigrit and Schlinker, because the construction
在建筑的一侧，它被废弃了。很快，他们的挣扎对孟菲斯人民来说变得显而易见。如果你和孟菲斯人谈论西德尼·施兰克，那感觉就像是，“施兰克”。你知道，就像那种纽曼式的发音。最终，施兰克和蒂格雷特公开闹翻了。他们的金字塔公司申请破产，该市将他们完全踢出了项目。金字塔的建设于1991年完成。实际建筑是在没有蒂格雷特和施兰克的情况下完成的，因为建设
that was largely paid for by public money. When the pyramid opened, it was the largest pyramid in America, and by some estimates the sixth largest pyramid on Earth. But the project was over budget, costing the public $65 million instead of $39 million. And it didn't have any theme parks or laser shows or even the famed Inclinator. In the end, it was just an arena. The pyramid opened to great fanfare in November 1991.
很大程度上是由公共资金支付的。当金字塔开放时，它是美国最大的金字塔，据一些估计，它是地球上第六大金字塔。但该项目超出了预算，花费了公众6500万美元，而不是3900万美元。而且它没有任何主题公园或激光表演，甚至没有著名的倾斜升降机。最后，它只是一个竞技场。金字塔于1991年11月盛大开幕。
But it was clear there were some unusual kinks to work out. Take for example, what happened on opening night when country music legends, Naomi and Winona Judd played a concert to launch the new venue. Russ Simons was the general manager at the time. And he says one aspect of the building that wasn't ready on opening night was the plumbing system. The pyramid sits below grade,
但很明显，有一些不寻常的问题需要解决。以开幕之夜为例，当时乡村音乐传奇人物娜奥米和威诺娜·贾德举办了一场音乐会来启动这个新场馆。拉斯·西蒙斯当时是总经理。他说，开幕之夜建筑中没有准备好的一方面是管道系统。金字塔位于地平面以下，
sits right on the level of the river. The plumbing designer had, we were supposed to have two, 3000 gallon per minute lift stations to lift... Look, there's a very technical explanation for all this, but basically the toilets overflowed and immediately flooded the building. The stage had to be sandbagged to stop water from getting into the electrical equipment. Russ remembers how despite all this, the Judds heroically got on stage and they still did their show.
正好处于河流的水平面上。管道设计师本应有两台每分钟3000加仑的提升泵来提升……看，这一切有一个非常技术性的解释，但基本上厕所溢出了，并立即淹没了建筑。舞台必须用沙袋围起来，以防止水进入电气设备。拉斯记得尽管如此，贾德母女还是英勇地登上了舞台，她们仍然完成了演出。
So myself and our head of guest experience, Rick Ferdette, we used a fireman carry to lift Naomi and Winona Judd to the stage. They had carried their shoes. They got on the stairs, they got their shoes on, sort of told me good luck, and they got up there and brought the house lights down and played their show from beginning to end. We lost a lot of shoes that night. Ross and his team managed to get things cleaned up and they fixed the plumbing, but there was another challenge to using the pyramid as a
所以我和我们的客座体验主管里克·费德特，我们用消防员背人的方式把娜奥米和威诺娜·贾德抬到了舞台上。她们带着鞋子。她们上了楼梯，穿上鞋子，算是跟我说了声祝你好运，然后她们走上去，调暗了室内灯光，从头到尾完成了演出。那天晚上我们丢了很多鞋子。拉斯和他的团队设法清理了现场，他们修理了管道，但将金字塔用作
concert venue. Most arenas are optimized for sound. By contrast, a pyramid shape is less than ideal for concerts. Here's Martha Park. The point at the top of the pyramid, it's like all the sound goes straight up, doesn't disperse, and then just goes, boom, and bounces back down to you. Like acoustically, there's nowhere for the sound to go, except just back and forth.
音乐会场地还有另一个挑战。大多数竞技场都针对声音进行了优化。相比之下，金字塔形状对于音乐会来说并不理想。这是玛莎·帕克。金字塔顶部的尖端，就像所有的声音都直冲上去，不会分散，然后就砰的一声，弹回给你。从声学上讲，声音无处可去，只能来回反弹。
And December was Van Halen, that's when they figured out they didn't have enough acoustics in the building and it was just a nightmare, like having a concert in a racquetball court. It's just a terrible sound. After the construction hype and the toilet flood and the big echo, within a few weeks, the pyramid started to
12月是范·海伦乐队的演出，那时他们发现建筑里的声学效果不够，简直是一场噩梦，就像在壁球场里开音乐会一样。声音太糟糕了。在建设炒作、厕所洪水和大回声之后，几周内，金字塔开始
find its footing. Russ Simons says his team added more soundbaffling, and Memphians came out in droves. Of course to see concerts, but also the arena's major draw. College basketball. Here is an exterior look at this stainless steel and glass beauty that now is dominating the skyline and certainly the drive along the river here it holds just over 20,000 and every seat is filled tonight. In 1992 the college basketball team the Memphis Tigers were led by a young
找到了立足点。拉斯·西蒙斯说他的团队增加了更多的隔音板，孟菲斯人蜂拥而至。当然是为了看音乐会，但也是竞技场的主要吸引力。大学篮球。这是这座不锈钢和玻璃美景的外部外观，它现在主宰了天际线，当然还有沿河的驾驶路线，它可容纳2万多人，今晚每个座位都坐满了。1992年，大学篮球队“孟菲斯老虎队”由一位年轻的
phenom named Penny Hardaway. They made the NCAA tournament, and their success drew rabid fans to the new stadium, which they nicknamed the Tomb of Doom. The pyramid became a place to be in Memphis. The Tigers had great crowds, and the arena drew in big names for concerts like Bruce Springsteen and the Grateful Dead. And later, a prize fight between Mike Tyson and Lennox Lewis. After a few years, the management team even started booking events in the unused space, but on a smaller scale than what was imagined by Schlinker and Tigrit. They booked an exhibition of artifacts from the Titanic, and yes, a display of treasures
天才球员佩妮·哈达威带领。他们进入了NCAA锦标赛，他们的成功吸引了狂热的球迷来到新体育场，他们将其昵称为“末日之墓”（Tomb of Doom）。金字塔成为了孟菲斯的一个必去之地。老虎队拥有很棒的观众，竞技场还吸引了布鲁斯·斯普林斯汀和感恩而死乐队等大牌音乐人来举办音乐会。后来，还有迈克·泰森和伦诺克斯·刘易斯之间的拳王争霸赛。几年后，管理团队甚至开始在未使用的空间举办活动，但规模比施兰克和蒂格雷特想象的要小。他们预订了泰坦尼克号文物的展览，是的，还有来自
from ancient Egypt. Okay, sure. The Luxor Casino in Las Vegas took away its crown as biggest pyramid in America in 1993, but that didn't matter. All in all, it seemed like the pyramid was becoming a success. I wish I could say this is how the story ends. With the pyramid, in spite of everything, rising in a blaze of steel and fiberglass and ancient Egyptian kitsch to become Memphis's beloved sports arena, living happily ever after. Of course, this is not what happened next.
古埃及的宝藏展示。好吧，当然。拉斯维加斯的卢克索赌场在1993年夺走了它作为美国最大金字塔的桂冠，但这并不重要。总而言之，金字塔似乎正在取得成功。我希望我能说这就是故事的结局。金字塔尽管经历了一切，在钢铁、玻璃纤维和古埃及媚俗的闪耀中崛起，成为孟菲斯深受喜爱的体育竞技场，从此过上了幸福的生活。当然，接下来发生的并不是这样。
Basketball had made the Memphis pyramid, and a decade later, basketball nearly destroyed it. Civic leaders in Memphis had always wanted a big league sports franchise, and in 2001, they finally got their chance. Well, the team's been in the league six years, and in that time, the Vancouver Grizzlies won 98 games. They lost another 352. So an announcement today that it's applied to move to an American city comes as no surprise.
篮球成就了孟菲斯金字塔，而十年后，篮球几乎摧毁了它。孟菲斯的市政领导人一直想要一个大联盟体育特许经营权，2001年，他们终于得到了机会。“好吧，球队在联盟里待了六年，在那段时间里，温哥华灰熊队赢了98场比赛。他们输了另外352场。所以今天宣布它已申请搬迁到美国城市并不令人惊讶。”
The Vancouver Grizzlies were the worst team in the NBA, and the city of Vancouver never showed up to the games. In 2001, on short notice, the owner of the Grizzlies decided to move them out of Canada and into the U.S. And with that, the Memphis Grizzlies were born. Though in the great tradition of the Utah Jazz, the name did not make a lot of geographic sense. This franchise came from Vancouver. That's why we're named the Grizzlies. Where's a grizzly bear around here, you know? The Grizzlies played their first three seasons in the pyramid, but the NBA made it clear that
温哥华灰熊队是NBA最差的球队，温哥华市从未出现在比赛中。2001年，在短时间内，灰熊队的老板决定将他们从加拿大搬到美国。随之，孟菲斯灰熊队诞生了。虽然按照犹他爵士队的伟大传统，这个名字在地理上并没有多大意义。“这个特许经营权来自温哥华。这就是为什么我们叫灰熊队。这附近哪有灰熊啊，你知道吗？”灰熊队在金字塔里打了前三个赛季，但NBA明确表示
the pyramid could not be a long-term home for the Grizzlies because it simply wasn't up to NBA standards. Basketball arenas were sort of undergoing this evolution. Here's Zach McMillan. He covered basketball for the Memphis Commercial Appeal. Zach says in the early 2000s, the business of sports in North America went through a rapid change. You were moving from a time when the point of a basketball arena was to get as many people as you could into the seats, balance supply and demand as best you could.
金字塔不能成为灰熊队的长期主场，因为它根本不符合NBA标准。篮球竞技场正在经历这种演变。这是扎克·麦克米兰。他为《孟菲斯商业呼声报》报道篮球。扎克说，在21世纪初，北美体育产业经历了快速变化。你正在从一个篮球竞技场的目的是尽可能多地让人坐进座位、尽可能平衡供需的时代走出来。
Maybe within five or six years, if you built a new arena, you really put an emphasis on the luxury suites. You wanted people paying premium prices to rent out those suites. And that's really how you could create the business model to make it work. Basketball in North America was becoming a big money sport. And that came with a lot of expectations. Arenas needed luxury boxes.
也许在五六年内，如果你建造一个新的竞技场，你真的会强调豪华套房。你希望人们支付高昂的价格来租用这些套房。这确实是你如何创造商业模式来使其运作的方式。北美的篮球正在成为一项大钱运动。这伴随着很多期望。竞技场需要豪华包厢。
They also needed fancy modern training facilities and a massive digital scoreboard and spacious locker rooms and lots of things the Memphis Pyramid lacked. So the Grizzlies' ownership made a fateful choice. They decided the pyramid wasn't worth the hassle. A new arena was built using public money, and the FedEx Forum opened in 2004. It became the new home for the Grizzlies, and to add insult to injury, it was clearly visible from the pyramid.
他们还需要时髦的现代训练设施、巨大的数字记分牌、宽敞的更衣室以及孟菲斯金字塔所缺乏的许多东西。所以灰熊队的老板做出了一个决定性的选择。他们认为金字塔不值得折腾。一个新的竞技场是用公共资金建造的，联邦快递广场（FedEx Forum）于2004年开放。它成为了灰熊队的新主场，而且雪上加霜的是，从金字塔可以清楚地看到它。
The new arena was much more conventional than the pyramid. For starters, it was actually arena-shaped. The fact that it's fun and it's a building that works well and the acoustics aren't maddening and stuff like that. Soon, the Memphis Tigers also moved to the Forum, and major concerts started getting booked there too. There was still an occasional show at the Tomb of Doom, but in 2007, Bob Seeger played the last concert ever held there.
新竞技场比金字塔传统得多。首先，它实际上是竞技场形状的。事实是它很有趣，而且是一栋运作良好的建筑，声学效果也不令人抓狂，诸如此类。很快，孟菲斯老虎队也搬到了广场，大型音乐会也开始在那里预订。偶尔还有演出在“末日之墓”举行，但在2007年，鲍勃·西格在那里举办了最后一场音乐会。
The Memphis Pyramid went from being a center of civic life to having zero tenants and zero prospects. While a pyramid is famously a very stable shape, there are good reasons they don't show up all that much in modern architecture. For example, pyramids just don't use vertical space very efficiently. Anyway, a few ideas were proposed for the Memphis Pyramid, but nothing seemed like an obvious fit. It could have been a museum. Like, you could have put attractions in there. But at the end of the day, why would you want to own the whole thing?
孟菲斯金字塔从市政生活的中心变成了零租户和零前景。虽然金字塔以非常稳定的形状而闻名，但它们在现代建筑中出现得并不多是有充分理由的。例如，金字塔对垂直空间的使用效率并不高。无论如何，有人为孟菲斯金字塔提出了一些想法，但似乎没有什么是明显的合适选择。它本可以成为一个博物馆。就像，你可以在里面放置景点。但归根结底，你为什么要拥有整个东西呢？
Clearly it never made sense to anybody. The pyramid was no longer useful and it was a target for negative press, including attention from a very confused, very misinformed, very malicious radio host. Thanks to radio talk show conspiracy theorist Alex Jones, the empty arena is again in the national spotlight as a cornerstone of one of his rants against the occult. And you can see the Memphis pyramid built back in the early 1990s.
显然，这对任何人来说都没有意义。金字塔不再有用，它是负面新闻的目标，包括来自一位非常困惑、非常误导、非常恶意的电台主持人的关注。多亏了电台脱口秀阴谋论者亚历克斯·琼斯，空荡荡的竞技场再次成为全国关注的焦点，作为他反对神秘主义的咆哮的基石之一。“你可以看到孟菲斯金字塔建于20世纪90年代初。”
In classic Alex Jones fashion, this conspiracy wasn't really based on anything except a misreading of some internet rumors. By 2008, the pyramid laid off all of their employees, except for one guy. Basically, a lighthouse keeper, just there to oversee the place. Soon all the pyramid was being used for was one-off stuff, like firefighter training. So now you have this big old 20,000 seat, 321 foot tall pyramid,
以典型的亚历克斯·琼斯风格，这个阴谋实际上并没有基于任何东西，除了对一些互联网谣言的误读。到2008年，金字塔解雇了所有员工，只剩下一名员工。基本上，一个灯塔管理员，只是在那里监督这个地方。很快，金字塔的所有用途都只是零星的东西，比如消防员训练。所以现在你有了这个巨大的2万个座位、321英尺高的金字塔，
and a neat building that you can't put anything in. It seemed like the great American pyramid had become the city's great folly. Nobody wanted to knock it down, but nobody wanted to move in either. That is, until someone took up residence and completely transformed the space. This is a live look. Construction is well underway at the pyramid in downtown Memphis to turn the former Tomb of Doom into one of the largest Bass Pro shops in the country. In 2010, the hunting and fishing store Bass Pro Shops announced a plan to buy the pyramid and use it as their flagship location, which turned out to be the biggest Bass Pro shop in America. The city
以及一栋你无法放入任何东西的整洁建筑。看起来伟大的美国金字塔已经成为了这座城市的巨大愚行。没有人想把它拆掉，但也没有人想搬进去。也就是说，直到有人入住并彻底改变了这个空间。“这是一个现场直播。孟菲斯市中心的金字塔正在进行大规模施工，将前‘末日之墓’变成全国最大的Bass Pro商店之一。”2010年，狩猎和钓鱼商店Bass Pro Shops宣布了一项计划，购买金字塔并将其用作他们的旗舰店，这最终成为了美国最大的Bass Pro商店。该市
of Memphis was more than happy to lease to Bass Pro because they were thrilled that anyone was interested in taking over the property. In 2015, the new store dubbed Bass Pro Shops at the Pyramid was opened. Now look, it doesn't make a lot of obvious sense to take a giant pyramid-shaped basketball arena and to make it into an outdoorsy amusement park slash store, but when you think about it, nothing really makes sense for this building.
孟菲斯非常乐意租给Bass Pro，因为他们很高兴有人对接管该房产感兴趣。2015年，名为“金字塔里的Bass Pro Shops”的新店开业了。现在看，把一个巨大的金字塔形篮球场变成一个户外游乐园兼商店并没有太多明显的意义，但当你想到它时，对于这栋建筑来说，没有什么真正有意义。
Ultimately to me, I think the pyramid was a really absurd plan and that the Bass Pro just happens to feel like just absurd enough to work when other things were maybe too serious. Legend has it that Bass Pro bought the pyramid because their CEO, Johnny Morris, was on a fishing expedition that caught a 30 pound catfish on the Mississippi River, which he saw as a good omen. While I have a lot of questions about this story, Morris and Bass Pro did not respond to my request for an interview. But there's another less magical reason Bass Pro probably wanted this space. Memphis, Tennessee is close to some of the nation's best hunting and fishing spots. When you think about it, you got the Mississippi River right there. And 70% of the migratory waterfowl fly from Canada down through this waterway here, the Mississippi Waterway. So over here in Stuttgart, Arkansas, 60 miles to our east, is the duck calling championships
最终对我来说，我认为金字塔是一个非常荒谬的计划，而Bass Pro恰好感觉足够荒谬，可以在其他事情可能太严肃时发挥作用。传说Bass Pro购买金字塔是因为他们的首席执行官约翰尼·莫里斯在一次钓鱼探险中在密西西比河上捕获了一条30磅重的鲶鱼，他将其视为一个好兆头。虽然我对这个故事有很多疑问，但莫里斯和Bass Pro没有回应我的采访请求。但Bass Pro可能想要这个空间的另一个不那么神奇的原因是。田纳西州的孟菲斯靠近全国一些最好的狩猎和钓鱼点。当你想到它时，密西西比河就在那里。而且70%的候鸟从加拿大沿着这条水道飞下来，这里，密西西比水道。所以在这里，斯图加特，阿肯色州，在我们东边60英里处，是鸭子叫声锦标赛
each year. The ducking capital of the world. When I visited the pyramid earlier this year, I was pretty into it. I loved taking rides on the pyramid's ludicrously tall elevator, though I have to tell you, it's a regular vertical elevator. They never ended up building the inclinator. On the elevator, visitors are regaled by a recording from a local TV fishing legend,
每年一次。世界鸭子之都。今年早些时候我参观金字塔时，我非常喜欢它。我喜欢乘坐金字塔那荒谬的高电梯，虽然我必须告诉你，它是一部普通的垂直电梯。他们最终没有建造倾斜升降机。在电梯上，游客们会听到当地电视钓鱼传奇人物的录音，
who tells the story of Johnny Morris' party catching that fortuitous catfish. Hello everybody, I'm Bill Danics. Did you know that you're taking a ride on the nation's tallest freestanding elevator? This elevator and everything you see when you look down would never have happened had it not been for one big old Mississippi River blue cat. One day, my dear friend... The elevator takes visitors up to the spire of the pyramid, which overlooks the Mississippi River from the vantage of a glass-bottomed observation deck. It's all pretty spectacular.
他讲述了约翰尼·莫里斯捕获那条幸运鲶鱼的故事。“大家好，我是比尔·丹尼克斯。你知道你正在乘坐全国最高的独立式电梯吗？如果不是因为那条密西西比河大蓝鲶鱼，这部电梯和你向下看时看到的一切都不会发生。有一天，我亲爱的朋友……”电梯将游客带到金字塔的尖顶，从玻璃底观景台俯瞰密西西比河。这一切都非常壮观。
And at first, I was having a lot of fun. But on my second day, my mood started to turn. Hunched over my desk, under the watchful gaze of two taxidermy deer heads, a melancholy crept in. I realized I hadn't seen daylight for 16 hours, and to leave the building, I'd have to cross a sea of parking lots and walk under a highway to get anywhere. I started to feel a little wistful. I can go kind of dark about the Bass Pro Shop with the fake cypress trees when it's like, you know, most of the bottomland hardwood forests in this area have been destroyed and there's not a lot of cypress trees just hanging out, you know, that there would have been. And to come into this place and it's dark and there's these fake cypress trees, it
起初，我玩得很开心。但在第二天，我的情绪开始转变。我蜷缩在办公桌前，在两个动物标本鹿头的注视下，一种忧郁感悄然而至。我意识到我已经16个小时没见到日光了，要离开这栋建筑，我必须穿过一片停车场，走在高速公路下才能去任何地方。我开始感到有点惆怅。“我对Bass Pro Shop里那些假柏树感到有点阴暗，当它是，你知道，这个地区的大部分底层硬木森林已经被摧毁了，没有多少柏树只是闲逛，你知道，本来会有的。来到这个地方，它是黑暗的，有这些假柏树，它
just can make me feel kind of sad. I got to thinking about how this place was pitched as a project with so many civic virtues, an arena that would also host museums and redevelop a historic neighborhood. Instead, its fate was to become a mall. I have to say, though, talking to Memphians about this, most of them did not share the concern. They were pretty happy about how the pyramid turned out. The ones that wanted to have problems with it do. People that don't like something, want to have problems, want to fuss about it, yeah.
只会让我感到有点难过。”我开始思考这个地方是如何被推销为一个具有如此多市政美德的项目，一个也将举办博物馆并重新开发历史街区的竞技场。相反，它的命运是成为一个购物中心。不过，我必须说，与孟菲斯人谈论这件事，他们中的大多数人并不分享这种担忧。他们对金字塔的结果感到非常高兴。“那些想要有问题的人确实有。不喜欢某事的人，想要有问题，想要为此大惊小怪，是的。”
They're gonna have problems with anything. Jimmy Ogle thinks complaints like this one are missing the bigger point. Because what exactly was the alternative for the pyramid? This is a drain on the city if it left Fankit. What can you do to get the private sector involved? So these are private dollars, private accounts, so it's the stimulus jobs, all the other stuff,
“他们会对任何事情都有问题。”吉米·奥格尔认为像这样的抱怨错过了重点。因为金字塔的替代方案到底是什么？“如果它离开Fankit，这对城市来说是一种消耗。你能做些什么来让私营部门参与进来？所以这些是私人资金，私人账户，所以它是刺激就业，所有其他东西，”
tax revenues. The Bass Pro has become a tourist magnet, bringing in millions of people a year. In a way, it's now fulfilling its original promise. Totally safe environment, enclosed, a wonderland of outdoor things. It's just a kid's eyes just pop out of their heads when they go out on that floor. The people I spoke to are largely at peace with how everything turned out. I was surprised to discover even my Egyptologist seemed pretty cool with it.
税收收入。Bass Pro已成为旅游磁石，每年带来数百万人。在某种程度上，它现在正在实现其最初的承诺。“完全安全的环境，封闭，户外事物的仙境。当孩子们走到那个楼层时，他们的眼睛简直要从眼眶里跳出来。”我交谈过的人大多对结果感到平静。我很惊讶地发现，即使是我的埃及古物学家似乎也对此感到很酷。
Here's Chris Elliott again. I suppose the simplest way I can put it is to say that it makes me happy that the pyramid is still there. How many pyramids of this size have you got in the United States? Not enough, I think, to just sort of casually dismiss it. Many urbanists agree with this, and they say the Memphis Pyramid is a success story. The pyramid has become this place of rebirth, an abandoned building that has found new life despite formidable odds. But it's also a place of death.
这是克里斯·埃利奥特。我想我能说的最简单的方法是，金字塔还在那里让我感到高兴。你在美国有多少这种规模的金字塔？我想，不足以就这样随意地忽视它。许多城市规划者同意这一点，他们说孟菲斯金字塔是一个成功的故事。金字塔已成为这个重生的场所，一栋在艰巨的困难中找到新生命的废弃建筑。但它也是一个死亡的场所。
Of course, an Egyptian pyramid is a tomb, and the Memphis Pyramid, it represents the death of intention. I guess when I think about the pyramid, what I think it means is that any attempt you have at creating a space to project a single story is ultimately going to fail, and that what might work better is letting the world come in instead and letting you know what that space could mean, and to be open to a space telling a different story of itself than the one you expected. The Memphis Pyramid is proof that no matter what architects and planners and dreamers envision for a place, ultimately, every building has to find its own way.
当然，埃及金字塔是一座坟墓，而孟菲斯金字塔，它代表了意图的死亡。我想当我想到金字塔时，我认为它的意思是，你试图创造一个空间来投射一个单一故事的任何尝试最终都会失败，而可能更好的是让世界进来，让你知道那个空间可能意味着什么，并对一个空间讲述一个与你预期的不同的关于它自己的故事持开放态度。孟菲斯金字塔证明，无论建筑师、规划者和梦想家为某个地方设想什么，最终，每一栋建筑都必须找到自己的方式。
In 1991, Russ Simons made a shocking discovery at the top of the Memphis pyramid. We'll tell you about that after this. And we are back with Chris Berube. Hey Chris. Hey Roman. So Roman, I have to tell you about a footnote in the saga of the Memphis Pyramid. So you remember we talked about a guy named John Tigrit in the story? Yeah, of course. He was one of the businessmen who wanted to run all the attractions beneath the bleachers of the pyramid.
1991年，拉斯·西蒙斯在孟菲斯金字塔顶部发现了一个惊人的发现。我们将在之后告诉你。我们回来了，和克里斯·贝鲁比在一起。嘿，克里斯。嘿，罗曼。所以罗曼，我必须告诉你关于孟菲斯金字塔传奇的一个脚注。所以你记得我们在故事中谈到了一个叫约翰·蒂格雷特的人吗？是的，当然。他是那些想要经营金字塔看台下所有景点的商人之一。
That's right. So I bring him up because actually I want to talk about John Tigrit's son for a second. Okay. Okay. So John had a son named Isaac Tigrit, who was famous, among other things, for co-creating the Hard Rock Cafe back in the 1970s. Of the ubiquitous t-shirt fame, Hard Rock Cafe. That's exactly the one, yes. So he's a really interesting character. Like Isaac Tigrit, you know, created the Hard Rock Cafe, famously traveled across America
没错。所以我提到他，因为实际上我想谈谈约翰·蒂格雷特的儿子。好的。好的。所以约翰有一个儿子叫艾萨克·蒂格雷特，他因在20世纪70年代共同创立硬石餐厅而闻名，除其他事项外。那个无处不在的T恤名声，硬石餐厅。正是那个，是的。所以他是一个非常有趣的角色。就像艾萨克·蒂格雷特，你知道，创造了硬石餐厅，著名地穿越美国
on his own rail car for a while. There's just so much going on in this guy's biography. It's really interesting. That's remarkable, okay. So when the pyramid was being built, John Tigrit, one of his promises was he was going to bring in his son Isaac to put a hard rock cafe in the pyramid, right? And that never ended up happening. But the son, Isaac Tigrit, he did put something else in the pyramid. So Isaac had access while it was being built. And when nobody was looking, he snuck in and he went up to the top of the pyramid
在他的私人火车车厢里待了一段时间。这个人的传记里发生了很多事情。这真的很有趣。这太了不起了，好的。所以当金字塔正在建造时，约翰·蒂格雷特，他的承诺之一是他要带他的儿子艾萨克进来，在金字塔里放一个硬石餐厅，对吧？那最终没有发生。但儿子，艾萨克·蒂格雷特，他确实在金字塔里放了别的东西。所以艾萨克在它建造时有访问权限。当没人注意时，他溜了进去，他爬到了金字塔的顶部
and he hid a good luck charm in the rafters and he never told anybody. Oh, a good luck charm. Okay, tell me about it. So Roman, this whole thing is gonna blow your mind. Like everything else with the pyramid, it's the wildest of possibilities. So I heard this story from Russ Simons,
他在椽子里藏了一个好运符，他从来没告诉任何人。哦，一个好运符。好的，告诉我关于它。所以罗曼，整件事会让你大吃一惊。就像金字塔的其他一切一样，它是最狂野的可能性。所以我从拉斯·西蒙斯那里听到了这个故事，
who you may remember was the former general manager of the pyramid in the 90s. Isaac Tigrit got a group of people together. Somehow co-opted a security guard and they took ladders and welding the same color as the steel, and they welded it, and it was like directly in the center of how the pyramid comes together. So Russ is running the pyramid, he's doing management stuff, and you know, he looks around and he notices this box,
你可能记得他是90年代金字塔的前总经理。艾萨克·蒂格雷特召集了一群人。不知何故拉拢了一名保安，他们拿着梯子和与钢材颜色相同的焊接材料，他们焊接了它，它就像直接在金字塔汇合的中心。所以拉斯在经营金字塔，他在做管理工作，你知道，他环顾四周，他注意到了这个盒子，
and he's thinking like, okay, that shouldn't be there. Like, what is this? I got my workers and Sawzall's and our equipment, all that, and ladders. We traipsed up those steps and we went and we knocked the welds off and we brought the box down. So Russ and his team, they take down this box. They have no idea. Isaac Tigert has put it there. And they're thinking like, is this dangerous? Like, what is this mystery box? So the first thing they do is they actually call the city and the county who are like, we'll send some representatives
他心想，好吧，那不应该在那里。就像，这是什么？我有我的工人和往复锯和我们的设备，所有这些，还有梯子。我们爬上那些台阶，我们去把焊缝敲掉，我们把盒子拿了下来。所以拉斯和他的团队，他们拿下了这个盒子。他们不知道。艾萨克·蒂格雷特把它放在那里。他们心想，这危险吗？就像，这个神秘盒子是什么？所以他们做的第一件事是他们实际上打电话给市和县，他们说，我们会派一些代表来。
over, so everybody gathers around, they're looking at this box and they all decide, okay, look, let's just open it up and let's just see what's inside. We brought the crew in and we knocked the cover off the box. So Russ says he and his crew were opening it and inside the box, there is the box. So Russ says he and his crew were opening it and inside the box there is another box. And the second box, it's velvet.
结束了，所以大家都围了过来，看着这个盒子，他们决定，好吧，看，我们把它打开看看里面有什么。我们把工作人员叫来，把盒盖拆了下来。拉斯说他和他的工作人员正在打开它，盒子里还有一个盒子。第二个盒子是天鹅绒做的。
And the second box was not a normal box, it was more like a puzzle box, like you had to flip a bunch of switches and stuff to get it open. The box opened by swinging the sides out and up and all of that, and then the box opened, and when we opened the box, a whole bunch of gray powder came out, right? And everybody's like, oh man, what is that? So people are, you know, clearing out this gray powder,
第二个盒子不是普通的盒子，更像是一个益智盒，你得拨动一堆开关之类的东西才能打开它。盒子是通过向外和向上摆动侧面等方式打开的，然后盒子开了，当我们打开盒子时，一大堆灰色粉末冒了出来，对吧？大家都说，天哪，那是什么？所以人们都在清理这些灰色粉末，
the dust is settling, and then they look and inside the box they see a crystal skull. Huh, sorry, what? So it's a crystal skull, it's about the size of a fist, looks expensive, it's like, I guess the best comparison, Roman, have you seen a bottle of Dan Ackroyd's vodka before? No, I can't say I've had the pleasure. Well, I mean, look, he sells vodka and a crystal skull.
尘埃落定后，他们往盒子里看，看到了一个水晶头骨。哈，抱歉，什么？所以这是一个水晶头骨，大约拳头大小，看起来很贵，我想最好的比较是，罗曼，你见过丹·艾克罗伊德的伏特加酒瓶吗？不，我没见过。好吧，我的意思是，你看，他卖伏特加，还有一个水晶头骨。
It's not terribly complicated. Anyway, okay, so nobody knows what to make of this. They're like, what is this? So it turns out Isaac Tigrit had put it up there, apparently on the advice of a religious guru he was following who told him it would bring good luck to the pyramid. I have to be honest, the details on this are a little sketchy. I reached out to Isaac Tigrit to talk about the story. He did not get back to me. I'm sure he gets requests about this all the time, but after this, they weren't sure what to
这并不复杂。总之，好吧，没人知道这是什么意思。他们想，这是什么？结果发现是艾萨克·蒂格里特把它放在那里的，显然是听从了他所追随的一位宗教大师的建议，大师告诉他这会给金字塔带来好运。我必须诚实地说，关于这方面的细节有点模糊。我联系了艾萨克·蒂格里特谈论这个故事。他没有回复我。我相信他一直收到关于这件事的询问，但在那之后，他们不确定该
do with the skull. So it ended up in a vault in the Shelby County administration office. And Isaac Tiger gets wind of this and actually through his mother, he managed to broker a deal and in the end, he got the skull back from the county. Wow. This is so dramatic. Oh yeah. I mean, it's like everything in this story. It is just very dramatic.
怎么处理这个头骨。所以它最终被存放在谢尔比县行政办公室的一个保险库里。艾萨克·蒂格里特听说了这件事，实际上通过他的母亲，他设法达成了一项协议，最终他从县政府那里拿回了头骨。哇。这太戏剧性了。哦，是的。我的意思是，就像这个故事里的每件事一样。它就是非常戏剧性。
So of course the media gets ahold of this, right? And they publish a bunch of stories with headlines like Crystal Skull found at the pyramids, you know, belongs to Isaac Tigrit. And you may remember Alex Jones was involved with all this. He had said the pyramid was demonic. And this is the reason why. It's because he heard about the Crystal Skull and that's the reason it became the center of this conspiracy theory. Joan's so-called facts are mostly slanderous in the internet video entitled, Devil Pyramid Rotting in Memphis, but at least one of his statements is true. A crystal skull was discovered. Like everything with the Memphis Pyramid, it's a completely unexpected twist and turn in the story. I got to say, this is definitely one of
所以媒体当然抓住了这一点，对吧？他们发表了一堆标题为“金字塔中发现水晶头骨，属于艾萨克·蒂格里特”的文章。你可能还记得亚历克斯·琼斯参与了这一切。他说金字塔是邪恶的。这就是原因。因为他听说了水晶头骨，这就是它成为这个阴谋论中心的原因。琼斯所谓的“事实”大多是诽谤，在一段名为“魔鬼金字塔在孟菲斯腐烂”的网络视频中，但他至少有一项陈述是真的。发现了一个水晶头骨。就像孟菲斯金字塔的一切一样，这是故事中完全意想不到的转折。我不得不说，这绝对是
the more unpredictable ones I've ever covered for the show. I gotta say, this is definitely one of the more unpredictable ones I've ever covered for the show. I love it. Well, thank you so much, Chris, and thank you for venturing out to Memphis. So I grew up in Memphis, so this is very exciting for me to hear more about Memphis. So thank you. It's my pleasure. I hope I did your hometown justice with the story, Robert.
我为节目报道过的最不可预测的故事之一。我不得不说，这绝对是我为节目报道过的最不可预测的故事之一。我喜欢它。好吧，非常感谢你，克里斯，也感谢你冒险前往孟菲斯。我在孟菲斯长大，所以听到更多关于孟菲斯的消息让我非常兴奋。所以谢谢你。这是我的荣幸。我希望我用这个故事公正地对待了你的家乡，罗伯特。
You certainly did. You certainly did. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Chris Barupe, edited by Kelly Prime, fact-checking by Laura Bollins, mixed by Martin Gonzalez, music by Swan Real, and Jamila Sendoto Sinai, with Mia Byrne playing lap steel. Special thanks this week to Lewis Graham, Harry Diamet, Zach McMillan, Yang Yi, Tom Jones and all the delightful folks that Chris spoke to at the Memphis pyramid. Our executive producer is Cathy Tu, our senior editor is Delaney Hall,
你当然做到了。你当然做到了。《99% Invisible》本周由克里斯·巴鲁佩制作，凯利·普莱姆编辑，劳拉·博林斯核实事实，马丁·冈萨雷斯混音，斯旺·里尔和贾米拉·森多托·西奈配乐，米娅·伯恩演奏膝上钢棒吉他。本周特别感谢刘易斯·格雷厄姆、哈里·戴梅特、扎克·麦克米兰、杨毅、汤姆·琼斯以及克里斯在孟菲斯金字塔采访的所有可爱的人们。我们的执行制片人是凯西·图，我们的高级编辑是德莱尼·霍尔，
the digital director is Kurt Kohlstedt. The rest of the team includes Jason De Leon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Lay, Lashma Dawn, Jacob Medina Gleason, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of his logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the SiriusXM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California.
数字总监是库尔特·科尔斯特。团队的其他成员包括杰森·德·莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、薇薇安·莱、拉什玛·道恩、雅各布·梅迪纳·格里森、乔·罗森伯格和我，罗曼·马斯。《99% Invisible》的标志是由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作的。我们是SiriusXM播客家族的一员，现在总部位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的住宅区，向北六个街区的潘多拉大楼内。
You can find us on Blue Sky as well as our own Discord server. If you enjoyed this episode, there's going to be a special bonus episode all about Memphis, Tennessee later this week. You can find it in our podcast feed or at our website, 99pi.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在Blue Sky以及我们自己的Discord服务器上找到我们。如果你喜欢这一集，本周晚些时候将有一个关于田纳西州孟菲斯的特别奖励集。你可以在我们的播客订阅源或我们的网站99pi.org上找到它。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。